out of tonight's GOP presidential debate
here are five things we hope the
candidates will say even though they
probably won't we need stricter gun
control but here's why we won't hear
that the crazy influential National
Rifle Association has given a or A+
ratings to almost everyone on stage not
to mention the millions they donated to
Republican campaigns ben Carson and
Donald Trump both have said more guns
are the answer to mass shootings so it's
probably more thoughts and prayers to
gun victims tonight climate change is
real but here's the reality no one will
say that tonight they're all climate
change deniers or at least doubters and
why wouldn't they be since they're
backed by the donations of oil and gas
companies during the last presidential
election oil and gas companies gave more
than 70 million dollars to federal
candidates and ninety percent of that
went to Republicans Islamophobia is a
problem we're not going to hear that
tonight because the right has a rich
tradition of anti-muslim bigotry and
this has real life consequences a recent
survey found that sixty-six percent of
likely republican voters want a
temporary ban on all Muslims entering
the US Muslim American leaders say
there's been a huge uptick in hate
crimes against Muslims across the
country black lives matter GOP
presidential candidates have shied away
from commenting on the black lives
matter movement and in some cases
they've sought to delete gitam eyes it
saying it should be called the all lives
matter movement but that completely
discounts the unique struggles the
community faces for example studies show
that unarmed black men in the US are
seven times more likely than white men
to be killed by police
I won't support Trump as the nominee as
Trump's comments get crazier some
candidates are getting a little firmer
and criticizing him chris Christie
called Trump's plan to ban Muslims
ridiculous and Jeb Bush called him
unhinged but no one has gone so far as
to say that they wouldn't support him if
he got the nomination will they come out
and say that tonight probably not but
hey maybe I'm wrong these debates can be
unpredictable prove me wrong Republicans